Okay, so now that we have all the theory out of the way let's do a little workshop to show how all these different framework elements
Come together and we'll make a little prototype that shows
a character and possessing a character and loading a stream level, so
this is
This is the example that we're going to use today. I've just loaded the epic launcher
There's nothing special about this project. Just using the third-person template
I've changed the variant to platform and if you want to do that and you just need to give your project a name
You can just follow along with this and just watch along if you'd like
Or I will break down the individual steps if you would like to follow along
But let's dig into it so by default you'll see our scene and
Let's just figure out our world settings first. Let's see what kind of game settings we're using
So I'm just going to go to window
I go to world settings and you'll see world settings snaps here and you'll see my game mode is
The third-person game mode if I hover over this so if I press ALT and P to play the game
Which you can also just press the play button
But if I press ALT and P as the shortcut
You'll see that I spawn as this character and that all makes sense now this
character is being set from the game instance and
In our project settings, so if you're not sure where the project settings are just go to edit project settings and we can type game
Instance and you'll see a game instance class being set here. So we have two different elements going on
We have the game mode and if I drop down the game mode, you'll see the third-person character is being set there
So if you made a new character, you could plug in your character there
Which will do a very quick new character just to show that that behavior being set
You have your controller class, which we mentioned is the brain in the slide deck
And then we also have our game instance, which is holding some of the game behaviors
Which will extend to make our own game instance version
so
First thing we want to look at is why a character spawns the way it does and how it gets possessed
Now if I just move this player start over here
and if you ever need to add a player start you can just go to
Add the actor there and drag in a player start and that's fine to do that
I'm just gonna press ctrl and spacebar to load up my
Content drawer here and I believe in third person is probably where we'll find that character. Yes
so I'll drag in a character now if I
Removed my player start for example, and I just wanted to load as this character
Now if I press Alt and P to play the game
You'll see that I just spawned where the camera was
I spawned as a new player because the game mode is setting which player I spawn as
If I press Alt and P over here, you'll see that I'm spawning over here
So that's spawning in a new character. And again, if I add my player start here
You'll see that I just load at the player start no matter where my camera is. I'll just load at that player start
so what is it that's causing us not to
Take control as this character now in the details
You'll remember that we said each character has a controller that while the player is a controller
That can possess a character and if we type possess into the search bar here, you'll see that auto possess
Is disabled now
I'll go to player 0 here and I am always going to be player 0 as the first player in the world
And if I press Alt and P now, you'll see that I've not used that player start that was next to me
I've now used this
Character, so that's pretty interesting
If I don't possess this character by default
It'll just spawn me a new one at the player start and if I do want to possess it
It'll allow me to control that so that's already really interesting in that
I just have one controller one controller to rule them all me as a single-player game
Now this character here does not this case on the left does not have a controller
It's just the character with no controller whereas this playable character is
The character and what makes it playable is my controller being attached to that now to demonstrate that
I will go ahead and possess this other character just so you can see exactly what I'm talking about
So I'm gonna exit out of here. I'll select this character in the level
I'm going to open my level blueprint
So again, we're talking about a new concept in the level blueprint
That we went through in the slide deck
Now what I will do is I'll just delete these things for now. You don't need to delete them, but
You can do it just to clean things up
I'm going to type input F and I'm just gonna look for the F button here
The F button is not special, but I just want to use F for my little mechanic here now
I'm going to right-click and create a reference to the third person character
If you don't see that it's because you didn't have your character selected. So make sure you have your character selected
now I'm going to
Drag off here and type possess. No, I'm not I'm gonna move this out of the way
Sorry, I'm gonna right click and get the player controller first. So get player controller
And so this is our controller zero is the character that is a control that we default respond to
Let's drag off here and type possess
Now we've got possess there. So just reorder these and the pawn that we want to possess is now this
So let's compile. Let's save
Let's go back in. Let's press alt and P. So we are this there's only one controller that still exists now
Let's press F and now I am that character
Which is pretty interesting now if I just show you the differences here, so
You don't need to do this bit, but I'm just going to show you the color differences
So I'm just gonna get this green color. I'm just gonna duplicate it
It doesn't really matter what I call it just because it's a quick quick test
But if I just make a slightly lilac color
and assign
this
color to
The character should we say like this?
Let's just save everything
Let's press alt and P again. You'll see that's I mean I could have picked a stronger color
But you get the idea if I press F. I'm now this lilac colored character
That I've possessed. So there's still only one controller in this map. I am the controller and there's two characters
So there's one controller for two characters. I can switch my controller between possess and two characters
So hope that makes a bit of sense now to clean up this mechanic a little bit
What I'll do is I'll introduce the concept of the camera manager
So I'm just going to go back to my level blueprint. I'm going to get the player
Camera manager. I'm going to start the camera fade
Plug that in here. I will then add a delay
Just maybe move these out the way just tidy things up a little bit. Now. The delay is 0.2. That's fine
So I'm going to put the duration as 0.2 here
Now 0 is no fade 1 is a fade so I go from 0 to 1 over 0.2 seconds
So that's going to fade my camera. I'm going to select these two functions here ctrl C
Ctrl V to paste or you can just make them again. That's fine
And then this time I'll go from fade to no fade. So from 1 to 0
Over 0.2 seconds now, I'm going to compile save. Let's see what happens here
So I'm my character. I'm running around I press F I fade and now I'm this character
So you'll see a few different elements being used here
I've got my world settings that are set in my character that I should start as I
Then
Getting my controller and using the possess for the controller
And I'm also getting my camera manager which we mentioned in the slide deck and controlling the camera with this
So that's a few different components going on as well as this level blueprint, which is its own instance in the world. So
Just in this simple example, you can see very quickly. We just mocked up some nice cool gameplay here
And it's not as daunting hopefully as it felt, you know in the slide deck as we're going through these concepts
So I'm just gonna select all of these just by the left mouse drag in I'll press C to comment and I'll put
possess
Mechanic with fade or something like this. I'll change the color just to keep things nice and organized
And maybe change the font size to 40, but it just keeps things organized on our level blueprint
So that's our mechanic working
But now now what we'll do is we will
Store some kind of score value in our game instance
which if you remember the instance is the thing that
Persists across multiple levels. So let's go ahead and create a new game instance
So I'm going to press ctrl and space bar. I'll go to my blueprints folder here and
It doesn't matter which folder you put it in but I'll just put it in this third person
I'll go to a new blueprint class. I'll drop down all classes and I'll type game instance here
So I want the game instance there. So I'll select that and I'll just follow the same naming convention
I'll just call this BP third person and then I'll put game
Instance, there we go. So I'll double click this
Now game instance is there now just because we've created it does not mean it's assigned
So let's go back to our project settings. If you close the project settings window, just remember go to edit project settings
Type game instance at the top here and let's just plug in our new third person game instance
So just select it from the drop-down menu or I already had it selected. So I just selected it from the content browser
So, let's just check that this game instance is being used
Let's create a game instance and have begin play I guess
Let's just take our word for it. And let's just see see what happens. I'm sure it is being used. I'm pretty confident
But let's just go back to our third person level
And let's go to the end here
So on possess we'll just do a simple mechanic of adding some kind of score value to the game instance
So let's go to our game instance. Let's add a variable here and call it score
Let's change the variable type to an integer and you don't need to do this overall
But just to keep things organized. I'll just do game play
Mechanic something like this. And so now we've got a section here called gameplay mechanic
The cool thing here is that I did not put a space between the Y and the M
But I put a capital letter for the M and it automatically knows to create a space there. So that's kind of nice
I'll just compile and save so this is where our score is being saved
Now we want to in our third person level blueprint. We want to get game instance
This is a node that we mentioned in the slide deck. We want to cast to the third person game instance
So we want to get a reference directly to this new class that we created
We want to get the score and just remember this score is the gameplay mechanic variable that we created if we had called this
something else in here then that would be called something else and
What we will do is we will do out the plus button on our keyboard
So if you press shift and and the plus key that will load it up
And what we want is we want to have increment in there
So it'll essentially just add one to the score
Now we want to drag out and type score again
set score and
We'll just do that now just to check the score has
Incremented correctly, I'll do a print string. I'll drag that into there and
I'll just make it blue for example. I think I selected lilac. But anyway, that's fine. It seems like we're in a lilac mood today
compile save
Now when we possess the new character, it should add one to our score and give us a value of
Press play. So we're running around we press F
Now we've got a value of 1 so that's good. That's working so far
now the difficulty comes is this is stored on the level blueprint and
As we mentioned in the slide deck, it's not the cleanest way to store
Information like I every time I added a score I'd have to do it here and I'm not sure
Inside of the game instance what is happening
So just as a quick that this this would be fine to leave this way, but just as a quick cleanup example
I'll actually just add this
Scripting inside the game instance. So I'm gonna go back to my game instance
I'm gonna right-click I'm gonna type custom event and I'll do add score
Now I'll get the score holding down ctrl and dragging it out
To set the score you hold down alt to drag that out
So ctrl to get alt to set alternatively if you just drag it'll ask you which one without holding a button
It'll ask you which one so when we get the score we want to do the plus
increment exactly the same scripting we want to set and
Then let's do a little print string just to confirm
The current value and actually what I could do as well, this is a very quick
Quick thing if you want to do this as a little trick
You can do this type of thing
Where we could do current score
And this is just an append function if I drag off here and type append if you want to get that
And then this will append current score space with the current score and that's just a nice little
Cleaner way of doing it. I'll make it green
If I compile and save and I go back into my third person now, all of this is now irrelevant
So I'll just click that now I drag off the blue pin and type add score
Now that add score is now there if I double click add score
it's now there in the game instance, and that is a cleaner way of
Setting it rather than it living on the level blueprint scripting
Now that add score wouldn't have been possible to get from here because I've not got the third person game instance
This is just a generic game instance where I need to cast to the third person to get the score
So just keep that in mind
Now, let's see if it still prints the correct value just to test this out. So we'll press play
We'll press F
Current score is one. So that's great. Our game instance is working exactly how we want it to do
Now we want to load a new level and make sure that game instance
Remembers our score and it will do by default because game instance if you remember persists across levels
And we just want to check that. So what I'll do is I'll make a brand new level. I
will
what I'll do is I go to file save current level as and
I think are we in the third person?
Yeah, we've got third person level here and I'll just call this level 2 for example. So let's save as level 2
Now what I can do is I can go to my level blueprint
I don't need any of this script in because we're in level 2 right now
I'll find this color
so if you're in the third person folder here and you have the the colors, I'll just duplicate this again and
Let's maybe make an orange color. This is purely for visualization. This is not functional
So you don't need to follow along with this. I'm just proving that our game instance is the way it is
What I did was I recolored the first game instance and now our characters gone yellow
Which is fine and our level will be pink
Let's go with it
So let's make our level pink
Let's just get all these I don't need to do too many to prove my point
Let's just say a level 2 is a nice lilac staying in the theme of our LIGO work theme day
Okay
Saving everything now. Let's go back to level 1
Level 1 is green. Now. We got the yellow character, which is all fine. And
if I load level 2 level 2 is
Lilac okay. I'll just delete this character actually for level 2 because we don't need the second character
What I'll do though is I'll go to my level blueprint in level 2
right click begin play and
I'll delay for a second just to make sure the levels loaded correctly. Maybe I'll delay for two seconds now
I'll get the game instance and I'll say
Third person and I just want to get the score and check this
So I just want to check the current score
now what I'll do is I'll
Go to my game instance and I'll append this little thing here just because I want to copy and paste this you could just create
It yourself, but I'm just saving a bit of time here and I'll put the score into there like that now
Hopefully just buy it. Well, I'll just show you now by default if I play this game
Current score after two seconds is zero. So we know in the lilac, you know ish level
We still got some green, but let's call it a lilac level. The score is zero
now let's go into the first level and now let's
play and
possess
Current score is one. Okay. So now let's load into the second level and let's check
Our score is still one
So to do that we need to go to our level blueprint
For after we've added score. So after we possess
In the name of commenting. Should we just say add score to game?
Instance like this and then if we drag off here and we put open
Level so open level and if you press ctrl and spacebar to open your drawer
I'm just gonna press f2 to rename this property and just ctrl C
Alternatively, you can just right-click rename
But I want to ctrl C and then ctrl V and that will get the name
You can manually type out that name, of course, but you want to make sure there's zero spelling mistakes
Otherwise, this won't work
So just copy the name in there
Let's maybe add a slight delay just to make sure like adding delays is never a bad thing
Always helps with gameplay. Let's just comment it load level
Two and let's see how we're getting on now
The level should print string that we've got a score of one in the second level fingers crossed. Let's see
current score one
current score two current score one
Perfect so as you can see everything is working exactly the way we intended it to so if I even
Test that again. So again, we're in the first level
And we press ALT and P we can see that we're running around
If I press F top left score of one current score current score one
So that means that we have taken our score across
Into the second level
And so that's a summary of everything that we've done. We've we've covered a lot of ground
Hopefully wasn't too quick and the main demonstration was just showing that we've got a game world here with some game settings
We've set our game instance in the project settings
So just remember we've got a custom game instance here. The game instance is the thing that persists across multiple levels
so if we want to score the store, sorry our score or health or
Pickups, it could be anything you want to store here, but that will persist across multiple levels that you want to load
We have a mechanic here in the level that first of all, we're getting our camera manager
Which is a gameplay framework class in itself
Then we're possessing a new character. So we have two characters in the world only one controller
Which is us and we go from one character to another we then use the camera manager again
then we're using the game instance to do a score and then we're opening a new level and
Using the level blueprint across levels means that we're storing values in the game instance. So
hopefully that's just a really nice straightforward example of
Using the gameplay framework inside of Unreal Engine